la pandémie de coved 19 n'a pas touché
tous les secteurs de l'économie ni tous
les travailleurs la même façon il ya une
étude de l'institut du québec
aujourd'hui qui confirme que
l'hébergement la restauration ont été
les secteurs les plus touchés mais
qu'est ce qu'ils en aient des autres
secteurs on va en parler avec jean guy
côté il est directeur associé de
l'institut du québec bonsoir monsieur
côté bonsoir
alors votre étude montre qui a sept
secteurs qui accapare 84% des pertes
d'emploi quels sont les secteurs qui ont
été les plus fragilisées cdp secteurs
comme la construction le transport
entreposage de commerce de détail comme
lé faire vite les autres et henri
culture c'est des secteurs qui ont été
fortement
outre l'hébergement et l'hotellerie est
l'attraction qui ont été fortement
affectés par la crise actuelle c'est
évident ceux des secteurs qui demande
beaucoup d'eau proximité donc la
distanciation sociale et pluton est
normal finalement c'est très visible que
ce soit deux secteurs qui y ait eu un
peu plus de difficulté dernier on a
moins parlé on a beaucoup parlé de la
restauration de l'hébergement évidemment
du tourisme
on a moins parlé du secteur de la
fabrication le transport l'entreposage
les défis pour ces secteurs lents
particulier c'est quoi est-ce que des
défis au départ parce que s'applique au
départ la pandémie on doit se rappeler
que quand on a confiné on accomplit de
façon murmure-t-on enfants dépendent
l'économie pour des bonnes raisons c'est
pas exactement comme 1,71 me la laisse
se développer
donc c'est des secteurs qui ont agi par
prudence donc et qui ont dit à l'argent
dans un foyer qu'il devait rentrer à la
maison
actuellement cependant on observe
certaines reprises en trois secteurs là
donc c'est des secteurs qui vont
reprendre du mieux à la différence
malheureusement des secteurs ont utilisé
de la culture hébergement restauration
qui peut de contrer des plus longtemps
avant de reprendre de façon plus
agressive alors accepté justement pour
ces secteurs là où la reprise sera très
long très lente
est ce que les travailleurs de certaines
industries devrait devrait carrément
lancé les ponts en douce ou réorienter
leur carrière est ce que c'est ça la
solution pour eux et pour l'économie du
québec
écoutez on peut pas décemment dire aux
gens quoi faire de s'ils veulent changer
de carrière c'est clair que les
prochains mois vont ici dans cette
industrie là haut niveau pour ses
employés là pour des raisons évidentes
de restauration et puis un peu souffler
cet été grâce au beau temps mais jean
difficile était raciste il donc il sait
ce qu avait à voir - 10 42 - dja sur le
plancher nom qui est des gens qui sont
intéressés d'aller dans d'autres
secteurs où des pénuries des pénuries
qui rit émergent les mêmes qui nous dit
qu'on observait avant attendait c'est ce
qui est des opportunités téléphone pour
se rendre près de 15 celles que vous
parlez quand vous parlez de pénurie
monsieur côté
le manufacturier est revenu en pénurie
et la construction est rapidement repris
donc on devrait retrouver des couleurs
d'étranglement de la construction s'est
rapidement donc il ya des secteurs
il savait de santé des secteurs qui
devront exiger des employés
supplémentaires pour accomplir leur
service est là et on leur production
donc ce secteur là qu'ils disent est
d'aider des pénuries avant la pandémie
sont vont être activement de retour au
pilori est ce que le gouvernement doit
intervenir monsieur côté pour faciliter
cette transition on pense par exemple
aux préposés aux bénéficiaires y avait
un déficit on avait besoin de main
d'oeuvre y avait des formations
accélérées encadrés par le gouvernement
est ce qu'on peut mener ce genre
d'opération là pour d'autres secteurs où
la main d'oeuvre va manquer c'est un
excellent exemple et propose au
ministère il y avait un manque donc y
est on est on est intervenus rapidement
pour combler ce manque
donc c'est un bon exemple quand le
système et quand le système le veut il
le peut donc s y ait d'autres secteurs
économiques sont en manque actuellement
quel un nombre important de gens qui se
cherchent des emplois aux trophées des
patrons des formes et rapidement ce
qu'ils sont et seront étaient laissés
pour compte des ces postes-là donc oui
effectivement il ya des moyens de le
faire des moyennes de très simple et la
plus donc des moyens de le faire chaque
entreprise doit prendre l'initiative ou
ce doit être une action coordonnée à
votre avis lorsqu'on a des métiers
protégés ou des métiers un peu plus
un peu plus coordonnée on peut
facilement se référer à l'élection pour
arriver à des formations rapides
ce travail qui est des entreprises qui
voient des opportunités pour aller
chercher des employés les former
eux-mêmes sauf si c'est un autre exemple
de choses positives et sauveterre les
prochains mois donc c'est un peu des
deux en fait donc 1 action coordonnée
gouvernementale ministériel ou même que
des anciennes commissions scolaires ou
en actions coordonnées ou certaines
entreprises dans certains secteurs qui
prend les choses des gens qu au pot
qualifie les qualifier le printemps
évidemment été du style pour l'emploi il
ya eu reprises pendant l'été souhaitons
qu'ils aient pas de deuxième vague même
si on a l'impression que ça nous pend au
bout du nez
si l'on devait se projeter là monsieur
côté c'est quoi les principaux défis en
matière d'emploi poste qu'ovide bah
écoutez vous allez avoir deux groupes
veulent avoir des industries qui auront
un surplus d'employés potentiels d'avoir
des industries corp voir manque flagrant
de personnes pour travailler
donc ça c'est le principal défi des
prochains mois
c'est comme comment équilibrer tout ce
dont des gens qui vont rapidement se
retourner ce marché du travail sont dans
les bonnes industries et des gens qui
vont chercher le lendemain du travail
donc le principe à ce défi dans les
prochains mois et devrait ramener cet
équilibre là le plus rapidement possible
espérons que la deuxième vague notre pas
trop trop difficile mais aussi quand
même se prépare donc voilà certainement
il ya des entreprises qui nous diront
entre temps la fin de certains
programmes comme la prestation
canadienne d'urgence à vomir faciliter
leur embauche de certains travailleurs
de ce côté je vous remercie infiniment
pour vos explications